knock-knock I am the one who knocks okay
chill out it's gonna be okay
yes it's El Camino which I can only
assume is Spanish for a Breaking Bad
sequel it's been six years since the
last episode of Breaking Bad and El
Camino hopes to offer some much-needed
closure for some of our favorite
characters in this video we'll be taking
a deep dive into the movie explaining
its ending and all its connections to
the Breaking Bad universe so throw your
housekeeper out the window because it's
time to cook um
youdon't odd the ending brings closer to
the character of Jesse Pinkman who we
last saw in the final episode of
Breaking Bad having driven off in Todd's
El Camino in fact the events of El
Camino pick up right where Breaking Bad
left off and even the introductory
credits use the el Caminos red paint job
seen here but El Camino isn't just a car
it's a symbol for Jesse's journey the
Spanish translation is the road or way
making it doubly fitting that the second
last shot of the movie is of Jesse going
down a new road a new path as he starts
his next chapter but to really
understand the ending we must first
start at the beginning with what is
arguably the most important scene in the
entire film important because it sets up
Jesse's internal need to set things
right start over start fresh one cut
put things right in context this scene
takes place before Jesse's capture but
after he's made a [ __ ] ton of money
cooking with Walter pegging this
flashback around season four before Mike
Ehrmantraut death also ironic this is
the same stream where Mike dies a place
where he talks about his future will
become the place where he will die but
mike says that it's impossible to set
things right so i kid that's the one
thing you could never do alluding to his
own backstory of killing his son's
murderers which is explored more in
depth in season 1 of better call Saul no
matter what you do it won't bring his
son back and no matter what Jesse does
it won't bring those helos back Jane for
example who we'll get to in a bit and
Andrea Cantillo who is killed in season
5 of Breaking Bad by Todd when Jesse
refused to cook for Jack Walker in his
gang Mike also sets up the thematic
premise of the film that only by
following your own path your el camino
that you can decide what's best for you
only you can decide what's best for you
Jesse Andy not him in this statement is
our first Walter White nod in the film
which there are a few and I'll point out
along the way Jesse asked Mike where he
would go if he could start over to which
Mike responds Alaska it's the last
frontier which is where Jesse ends up at
the end of the film not to mention the
close-up of the last frontier license
plate harkening back to Mike's line so
while it seems this scene may be an odd
way to start the film Vince Gilligan has
carefully crafted it to set up our
hero's internal journey his external
journey having to get away and start a
new life starts immediately after with
Jesse on the run from the police having
escaped Jack and his neo-nazi gang while
on the run we have Jesse hiding from the
cops preparing his gun about to get
caught when they rush by this is an
homage to the first episode of Breaking
Bad where Walter too thinks the sirens
he hears in the distance are coming for
him but they rush by him as well Jesse
heads to the only safe place he knows
skinny Pete's where it seems as though
Pete and Badger have used the money they
got for working with Walt in the final
episode of Breaking Bad to buy some
sweet new gaming
jessie is famished having spent an
eternity caged in Jack Walker's compound
and forced to cook meth this feeling of
being caged haunts Jessie and there are
several allusions to it throughout the
film for example when Jessie rests in
bed he's haunted by the flashback of his
cell and even though Jessie has made it
out of the cell he is still very much a
prisoner unable to live any semblance of
life now that he is on the run if he's
going to find his new path he needs to
get out of here we get a news report
that confirms Jessie is wanted by the
comps but it's only until later on in
the film that Jessie overhears a radio
report that Walter is in fact dead
putting to rest any conspiracy theories
that he has somehow survived although we
will get an important flashback which
we'll discuss in a bit
Jessie takes three important items from
Pete which help him set up his new life
one a burner phone which lets him call
his parents to a page from the telephone
book and three skinny Pete's car they
call on the aid of old Joe who we last
saw in the first episode of season 5 is
Breaking Bad he helped Walt Jesse and
Mike borrow a giant magnet from his
junkyard to destroy Gustavo Fring laptop
inside the police evidence Locker
Joe tells them that the El Camino sent
out a LoJack signal basically a stolen
vehicle recovery system which means the
cops will be on their way any minute
Pete devises a plan to throw the cops up
their scent by having Badger take his
car to the Mexican border when the cops
arrive he'll tell them Jesse came and
took that car to flee to Mexico this
also matches up with the end of the film
when Jesse asked ed to deliver a letter
and have him deliver it from Mexico City
because the police will likely pick it
up this will help in corroborating the
idea that he's in Mexico not Alaska more
on that in a bit
jesse takes a key from the same ring as
the el Caminos which will find is the
key to Todd's apartment this transitions
us to a lengthy flashback featuring Todd
Alquist who drives the El Camino to the
corner of Holly and eros I'm probably
mispronouncing that this is a nod to
Vince Gilligan's girlfriend Holly rice
and the Spanish word for rice is eros
Holly also happens to be the name of
Walter's daughter he takes his captured
prisoner knowing that if he were to
escape the first person he would kill is
Brock Conti oh the little boy of his
ex-girlfriend's so even though he
in the real world he's simultaneously
trapped back in present-day Jessie over
here's a radio talking about a murder
which the news claims to be Walt's last
kill a poisoning of a woman this is a
nod to Lydia the head of logistics at
Madrigal the company that supplied
Gustavo Fring with methylamine she was
killed in the final episode of Breaking
Bad when Walt put poison in her stevia
Jesse is off to find Todd's hidden stash
of money knowing that Todd is dead he
killed him at the end of Breaking Bad
he knows that Todd used to keep his
stash in encyclopedias but when he gets
there finds nothing but Jesse remembers
something else that Todd was always
meaning to find a new place to store his
stash one that would quote require some
engineering so he proceeds to completely
dismantle the house and I love this shot
here that Gilligan uses almost as if
we're watching a mouse in a cage
searching for its precious cheese we
also have this unique inclusion of a
tarantula which often symbolizes a cruel
or sneaky person much like Todd but we
also have it in a cage yet another
metaphor for Jesse's imprisonment
there's also the symbolism of the snow
globes which feature characters trapped
within a globe and perhaps the snow
hints at Jesse's eventual arrival in
Alaska although that might be a stretch
on the television Jesse's parents plead
for him to turn himself in when were
treated with another flashback where
Jesse helps dispose of Todd's
housekeeper Sonya he even has to ride
with the rolled up dead body in the back
of the El Camino which when the back is
put on it kind of looks like a funeral
hearse but it's when Jesse finds the gun
in the glove compartment and holds
taught at gunpoint that he eventually
breaks down and gives the gun over to
Todd he knows that killing Todd would
almost undoubtedly lead to Brock's death
and you can see it on his face how he
wrestles with this fact Jesse still
feels like he has no control over his
fate something he seeks to change by the
end of the film
Jesse ends up finding Todd's money in
the fridge when he's interrupted by to
fake police officers they're here
because they heard about Todd's stash
and with him now dead it's free Pickens
bonus points if you caught the vamonos
pest control shirt here where Todd used
to work one of the men turns out to be
Neil candy a welder who built Jesse's
prison cables in the meth lab he lets
Jesse go with 1/3
the money mostly because a gunshot would
alert authorities more so than the
feeling sorry for what he did to Jessie
we also get this shot in the flashback
of a picture of Andrea and Brock kept
there as a reminder to Jessie of what
will happen should he try to escape
using the torn out telephone page and
armed with almost a quarter of a million
dollars
Jessie visits Edie also known as they
disappear all he knows about him is that
he owns a vacuum shop and drives a red
car and more cage symbolism we last saw
Edie in the second last episode of
Breaking Bad where he helped Walt and
Saul Goodman disappear unfortunately for
Jesse he's 1800 short and until he gets
the money he's [ __ ] out of luck
it's also pretty fun that a vacuum shop
owner sucks up dirty people and turns
them into something clean kind of like a
vacuum Jesse uses the burner phone to
call his parents and tricks them into
meeting him knowing that comps would be
on his tail he does this to get two guns
from the safe but I think the most
heartbreaking scene here is when Jesse
takes a moment to look at the still
running tap showing him that his parents
literally dropped everything to see him
they still love and care for him even
with everything he's done he also knows
that if he does start a new life this is
likely the last he'll ever see of them
Jesse's last visit is to candy welding
where the boys are just having a casual
night with some prostitutes and in a
ballsy move that would make Walter White
proud he strolls in and confronts Neel
asking for the $1,800 but when Neal says
no he challenges him to a duel oh do I
do it now this was the only part of the
film where I kind of rolled my eyes why
would Neal offer to do a deadly duel
maybe it was the lines of coke they've
been doing but it seemed a little
far-fetched for me anyway Jesse pulls
the old gun in my pocket Rick and ends
up killing Neal and kaci thereby taking
all the money with enough to pay heed to
disappear with the majority of Jesse's
external goal to escape and start a new
life nearly complete we get two scenes
which help Jesse complete his internal
goal to move on and set things right
this is done through flashbacks with his
ex-girlfriend Jane and also Walter White
the first flash back with Walter occurs
sometime shortly after cooking their
first batch in the Winnebago which we
see here with the fresh bullet holes
from the pilot episode this scene is
great because it shows us how far
she has come as a character and also
because we get a cameo from one of the
most iconic television characters of all
time god damn right Walter is asking if
Jesse knows where they can find someone
who can buy 1.3 million worth of meth
alluding to their eventual hookup with
Duke Oh Salamanca we also get a reminder
that originally Walter was only in on
making this money just so that he could
make enough to support his family when
he's gone he was supposed to quit after
that it prompts the discussion of what
Jesse will do with the money he suggests
college where Jesse and Walter tossed
the idea of him being a businessman or
sports medicine doctor I'd like to think
that when Jesse starts his new life in
Alaska that's one of the things he'll
consider edy drops Jesse off in Alaska
to start his new life as Mr Driscoll
even quizzing him on aspects of his new
identity this is where Jesse gives at a
letter for Brock but what exactly is in
it well we may never know the exact
contents of what he said it's likely to
be an apology for bringing Andrea
Brock's mother into this whole mess
eventually leading to her death and with
Jesse having taken the entirety of
Todd's stash having killed the two
welders who knows if there are some
directions for a little bit of cash for
him to at the end of the film jesse has
not only escaped the literal prison of
his cage and being on the run but his
metaphorical prison of his life in the
drug game he is moved on his own way his
own El Camino in the final flashback
with Jane a scene which takes place
somewhere in Breaking Bad season 2 jesse
talks about how he thinks her philosophy
on going where the universe takes you is
pretty cool and that's what jesse has
allowed for almost his whole life he's
allowed the universe to make decisions
for him but Jane says she was talking
abouta for eclis and that philosophy is
[ __ ] I've gone where the universe
takes me in my whole life
it's better to make those decisions for
yourself and now with Jesse on the road
he's finally ready to start a life
making his own decisions starting life
anew thanks everyone for watching make
sure to give the video a like subscribe
and comment below about what you thought
of the movie you can also follow me on
twitter at think story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much